renaud muselier il ya trois jours samuel
pâtit professeur d'histoire-géographie
était à décapiter à la sortie de son
collège à conflans sainte honorine des
mobilisations ont eu lieu ce week-end
dans de nombreuses villes de france vous
avez participez vous à ces mobilisations
non je suis venu à paris a pour préparer
le congrès des régions de france gt
représenté à marseille par des conseils
régionaux ou dans toutes les villes de
fortes de la région qui avait analysé
les manifestations on est bien sûr tous
très sensibilisé moi tout
particulièrement en charge des lycées de
cent mille jeunes professeurs qui vont
avec un contact avec le rectorat donc on
a un problème à kerry finalement a assez
simple c'est qu'on a une société qui est
gangréné par cette pression permanente
de l'islamisme qui commence très tôt et
qui finit même traita en fonction des
âges est donc en nécessité de réagir
collectivement de façon très forte
yahia beaucoup leaders de droite qui
n'étaient pas présents dans ces
manifestations disant que l'heure n'est
pas aux mobilisations l'heure est aux
actes est ce que quand même c'est pas la
place de leader politique d'être dans
ces manifestations qui montre une forme
d'unité nationale face au terrorisme
alors je pense que c'est la place dans
les manifestations parce que après
l'effroi et le soutien et la
manifestation mais si si je reprends
avec l'arrière pensée derrière qui est
réel
c'est de dire bon les bougies c'est bien
mais ça suffit quoi donc à aller les
cartons avec des pancartes c'est bien
mais ça suffit qu'il ya un moment où il
faut agir
et quand on parle de l'unité nationale
c'est une unité nationale par rapport à
quoi
l'unité nationale par rapport à la
volonté d'être unis contre une guerre
civile potentielle car il parce que vous
avez aujourd'hui la nécessité d'être
unie autour de la liberté de l'égalité
de la fraternité qui est quand même qui
disparaît dans ce pays et donc vous
retrouver dans une situation où on
n'acceptera pas où les gens
n'accepteront pas de subir se joue
islami cette gangrène qui qui qui qui
gangrène notre dispositif républicain
est ce qu on ce qu'on voit le plus c'est
à dire est il trop tard ou n'est-il pas
trop tard
et moi je pense que fondamentalement il
n'est jamais trop tard et c'est l'heure
mais juste les républicains auraient dû
participer aux manifestations ce
week-end pour voir je pense que on
aurait pu y aller et enfin il y en a qui
sont d'aller l'option palais je sais
c'est en tout cas je ne crois pas que ce
soit un vrai problème pour nous les
républicains pour nous les républicains
c'est on est il faut être à l'action là
alors justement va parler des premières
mesures annoncées hier à l'issue du
conseil de défense
oui donc foot il accélérer la loi sur
les séparatistes et vont-ils prendre des
mesures encore plus ferme sur tout ce
qui ressemble à des tentatives de
séparatisme islamistes bien entendu que
oui
la loi finalement ne tombe bien parce
que ils vont être obligés ou une
vraisemblablement en tout cas j'espère
de la durcir par rapport aux voeux pieux
potentiel là il faut vraiment dans
l'action cette loi doivent être bâtis et
peut-être ça nécessitera d'ailleurs une
réforme constitutionnelle parce qu'on a
vu dans le passé que des lois de la
république n'ont pu être appliquée parce
qu'il y avait le conseil constitué de
blocs et parce que ce n'était pas ça ne
respectez pas la constitution mais dans
un pays qui a gardé des structures très
forte et qu'il faut respecter pour vous
et elle changer la constitution
ça dépend ce cas dans la loi mais je
pense que par rapport à vous avez
plusieurs problèmes vous avez tous le
renseignement ça c'est la loi de temps
de douter et puis vous avez le problème
de des réseaux sociaux qui n'était pas
elle veut imprimer dans la constitution
en tant que tel et on voit bien dans
cette affaire bien particulière mais
mais qui récurrente dans les
harcèlements donc dans cet appel à la
haine et au meurtre
on se retrouve dans une situation où il
ya une développement par les réseaux
sociaux de messages que aujourd'hui à
mon avis le dispositif législatif n'est
pas n'est pas organisé pour pour l'une
et donc il faut changer le droit le
conseil constitutionnel on s'en souvient
avait censuré la loi via c'est la loi
qui visait à lutter contre la haine sur
internet pour vous il faut changer la
constitution pour que d'un type de loi
ne soit plus censurer des ambiances que
l'on pour discuter la loi bien mais la
preuve est faite que la loi via attaquer
le problème des réseaux et qu'elle a
étét ok ou retoqué où on très diminuée
en tout cas à cause de d'une
constitution qui est inapplicable donc
il faut s'adapter à cette nouvelle
guerre c'est une vraie guerre et quand
je puisse quand je parle de la guerre
civile je suis suis très inquiet parce
que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
là on voit bien un besoin de ne pas se
laisser faire
mais comment se laisse pas faire si
l'état n'est pas là pour nous aider à le
faire collectivement c'est ça l'unité
mais moi je pense que là il doit y avoir
l'unité mais dans cette unité il doit y
avoir aussi des modalités de de
répression pour sauvegarder nos
professeurs nos lycées et nos cours
d'école notre vie quotidienne mais
justement puisque vous parlez de
guerrière xavier bertrand 10 l état
failli dans la lutte contre le
l'islamisme ne sommes pas encore entrés
en guerre contre l'islamisme vous êtes
d'accord avec lui
je pense qu'en tout cas on s'est pas
dotée de moyens et qu'on pèche par
faiblesse parce que on voit bien
d'ailleurs
c'est ensemble crée le malaise politique
dans une volonté de divers droite gauche
en marche tout ça c'est pas le problème
aujourd'hui c'est pour être libre dans
une vive libre en paix dans un pays la
france qui est le pays des droits de
l'homme cedh et de la libre expression
ou du respect de l'opinion du bout du
voisin et il est incontestable que quand
on a ces professeurs qui nous explique
madame milliers soit on envoie sur la
totalité des chaînes que leur hiérarchie
ne l'a pas soutenu que quand ils ont
porté plainte c'est les familles de
parents d'élèves qui ont finalement
réussi à faire partir le professeur ou
blanc forme de l'école j'aimais ça c'est
le monde à l'envers c'est là que c'est
le l'instituteur le professeur le
sachant le responsable de l'autorité sur
le celui qui transmet qui se retrouvent
pénalisés et qui se retrouvent viré du
lycée sous une pression islamisme ça
c'est pas possible comment les régions
qui ont charlie ici il faut le rappeler
peuvent aider les proviseurs et
professeur à renforcer cette citoyenneté
peut être pour protéger également alors
un autre niveau il ya plusieurs volets
il ya le volet de la sécurité dans le
lycée c'est à dire que je crois pour le
bâtiment la totalité des régions en tout
cas dans la mienne 100 % des lycées sont
mis en tient de recife
on a mis des médiateurs ce qu'on appelle
la garde régional des lycées qui permet
d'avoir à l'extérieur devant le devant
l'entrée du lycée ou à l'intérieur
discussions qui permettent d'avoir
les des remontées d'informations la
former notre personnel nos équipes aux
signes avant-coureurs de d'islamisation
ou en tout cas de radicalisation on les
a formés et à côté de ça on fera c'est
quand même cet après midi au congrès un
ouvrage que l'on distribuera à la
rentrée piloté par régions de france
mais dans chaque région de france piloté
par l'état dans deux régions sur les
l'addition de toutes les caricatures qui
ont eu lieu religieuse ou politique et
qui permettent le droit d'expression
avec un symbole fort par rapport à cette
liberté d'expression au fil des siècles
daumier à l'époque et aujourd'hui on
voit bien l'importance de prendre du
recul de la hauteur sur les choses et ça
ça fait partie de la pédagogie donc
travailler avec les recteurs travail
éducation nationale travailler pour la
protection travailler sur
l'environnement
et après il ya le travail sur les
réseaux qui tel un travail essentiel
aussi mais ça ça nous échappe donc ça
c'est la loi et l'importance d'impliquer
tout le monde xavier bertrand et eric
ciotti aussi demander un référendum sur
ces questions de laïcité est ce que vous
soutenez cette demande
je connais pas question donc je moi je
je suis pour lui pour affirmer le
principe de laïcité dans la constitution
oui oui bon ça mange pas de pain on sera
d'accord donc ça ok ça c'est bien
c'était nécessaire pour moi je ne veux
jeu on est on est contraint par quelque
chose s'est réalisée bien le fait que
les professeurs disent aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont pas soutenues par les archis
sas une chose réalisée bien le problème
de ces réseaux sociaux qui envenime tous
qui fabrique la haine et qui la
transmettent ça c'est une autre chose
regardez bien la loi qui n'est plus
adapté comme la loi via puis se
retrouver non constitutionnel et donc
pas suffisamment et donc et regardent et
bien moi c'est ça qui me gêne le plus
c'est ces manifestations de soutien
absolument nécessaire ces témoignages de
soutien c'est important de faire des
bougies ça va un moment quoi mais c'est
pas les bougies combat l'islamisme c'est
pas et donc il ya des choses qui sont à
mon avis beaucoup plus simple vous avez
des exemples
je pense que le ccf il faut le c'est un
organisme de propagande de diffusion de
haine qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
dissoudre voilà et donc c'est des
mesures très claires et très concrètes
au delà d'une démarche unitaire pour la
république justement gérald darmanin
eric dupond-moretti vont présenter cette
semaine un plan d'action contre les
personnes ou les associations proches
des milieux radicaliser qu'est ce que
vous attendez vous de ce plan d'action
j'attends que ce soit appliquée sur le
terrain ça va vous regarder avait
l'impression que ce n'est pas appliquée
sur le terrain
ben vous avez des mosquées salafistes et
qui sont là qui reste vous avez d'aider
des écoles musulmanes islamistes qui
sont souterraines mais qui existe comme
on le connaît et qui ne sont pas
dénoncés
vous avez du mal à les fermer parce que
vous la loi vous interdisez fermé parce
qu'ils organisent des protections pour
faire en sorte qu' il ya un moment ou un
autre c'est à quel moment la liberté
générale fait en sorte que l'on puisse
continuer à appliquer les lois mais
ferme et ceux qui veulent détruire la
république et il a il faut les combattre
et ça c'est ça doit s'inscrire dans la
loi donc j'attends de la loi des
modalités opérationnelles
ménard ses moniteurs opérationnel il
faut aider les hommes de terrain il faut
soutenir les professeurs
il faut soutenir les enfants dans les
cours d'école il faut faire en sorte que
les policiers la capacité d'action il
faut pas crier en permanence une
association de parents d'élèves qui
empêche la fermeture d'une école
islamistes quoi et ça c'est pas très
facile à écrire dans un texte de loi
pourtant ce mec club du bon sens et dans
ce contexte jean castex maintient sa
venue à votre congrès vous nous
confirmez ans il sera bien là pour
prononcer le discours de clôture
christine lagarde bien sûr le premier
ministre monsieur castex le président du
sénat les territoires unis avec françois
baroin et dominique bussereau la vie
continue dans ce pays et nous avons eu
un problème majeur sur le plan sanitaire
comme sur le plan économique et nous
estimons que dans le cas du plan de
relance il ya 100 milliards qui sont des
moyens conséquents pour aider notre pays
à se redresser en tout cas survivre
parce qu'ici non il se noie
nous estimons nous les régions avec
territoire unis que ça passe par nous
les territoires pour aller vite
voilà on a des moyens financiers on a
les tuyauteries qui existe il ya les
moyens de faire en sorte que ça aille le
plus près possible de nos concitoyens va
parler son la plus rapide possible on va
parler de ce plan de relance mais jean
castex
il s'exprimera donc cet après-midi
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous du
discours qu'est ce qu'il doit dire au
président de région premier ministre
d'abord
1 je salue le premier ministre sur la
qualité des relations qui l'organisé
entre lui et territoires en tout cas les
régions tout particulièrement puisque
nous allons signer avec lui un moyen
d'accélération du dispositif du plan de
relance avec la totalité des présidents
de région tous confondus des plus connus
ou moins connus des plus candidat à la
présidentielle au moins un candidat ou
de façon à ce que l'on puisse le plus
vite possible accélérer ce dispositif
donc c'est un renouveau dans les
relations partenariales parler de
révolution partenariale avec le
gouvernement aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation nous avons en place les
dispositifs dans ces dispositifs
il faut organiser des couples préfet de
région président de région pour être
opérationnel sur nos territoires dans le
contrat dans le cadre du contrat de
relance fonds européens font
structurelles aéronautiques tourisme de
tous les secteurs qui sont recrutés
directement impactés et contrat de plan
de relance 21 27 à signer d'ici la fin
d'année
c'est opérationnelle sous deux ans ça
c'est pas la mécanique d'état qui peut
pas y arriver tout ça c'est impossible
mais par contre notre état et est un et
indivisible mais pour autant il faut que
s'appuie sur les territoires qu'ils
fassent confiance donc jeudi au premier
ministre vous qui nous fait confiance
vous avec qui nous avons signé fait en
sorte que les ministères puissent rendre
opérationnel ce et display justement
quel aux actions pilotées en priorité
les régions et sur l'emploi
doivent-elles devenir ben on le chef de
file de celui qui a la compétence
exemple très concret vous avez
les fonds européens sur les fonds
européens vous avez une partie c'est
l'appât que fait d'ailleurs le feder
l'organisation du territoire
c'est la miss agriculture que le fait
que c'est nous nous estimons qu on est
plus efficace que sur l'emploi vous avez
dans ma région par exemple sur le fond
sur l'effet se sait qui sont les fonds
européens sur l'organisation que vous
avez des guichet unique et 12 c'est plus
du guichet unique ses multiples et donc
cette disparité administratives souvent
dues à des ministères qui veulent être
un état dans l'état en fait et qui
gardent leurs prérogatives pour mettre
en place des robinet partout pour
bloquer pour avoir le pouvoir de
décision
alors qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir le
devoir d' accélération vous dites ça se
passe bien le dialogue avec jean castex
mieux qu'avec edouard philippe si on
comprend bien c'est pas si mal que ça
avec edward liddy
mais je peux pas dire ça se passait mal
nous avons de bonnes relations
personnelles
jean-philippe son ami personnel je fais
la bise enfin tous les arbitrages nous
était négatif donc utile sur la mise à
l'herbe mieux sur le plan humain mais
sur le plan politique c'était inefficace
de regarder ce que nous a fait pénicaud
dans l'apprentissage c'est la caricature
de la caricature que par une compétence
qui est la tienne je te prends ton
argent que la tièche donne des résultats
que son étiage les accaparements qui
réussit excusez moi si vous vous
révoltez pack auto ça c'est que ce
moment-là vous méritez pas être
président je vois ça se passe bien donc
du coup avec les gens avec jean castex
vous demandez-vous plus de
décentralisation est ce que vous sentez
que le premier ministre et jette une
couronne qui sera en charge du texte
décentralisation sont prêts à vous
donner
la décentralisation que vous souhaitez
en partie oui mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est clair que ce soit
le premier jean castex thomas labourot
je crois que il est clairement dans le
cas du convient donc aux vie d'un vaccin
oms et on a vraiment montré qu'on était
plus agile plus rapide plus efficace on
a montré qu'on était une île en état
dans le zéro polémique à vis du
gouvernement
alors qu'on aurait pu en dire des choses
donc on voulait ne pas ajouter de la
difficulté dans le chaos est bon vous
savez le début nous avait dit en début
d'année un hymne à l'amour au lait 3d
décentralisation déconcentration
différenciation nous je l'avais dit
on veut j'ai ouï avant il faut confiance
car tes compétences a donc les trois
qualifications et 3 c est bien la crise
du covan a fait en sorte qu'on fait les
trois cd 2 c sur les trois et un peu les
deux des sur les sur les 3 et donc on va
on a grâce à cette crise à rapprocher
des positions qu'ils ont permis de
signer aujourd'hui avec le premier
ministre
décrire les lois de décentralisation qui
ont commencé à être programmés dans le
cadre de l'action de territoire unis
sous l'autorité du président larcher et
qu'il ya un gros travail qui était
fermement
alors soit on existe une opposition
politique droite gauche on n'est pas
d'accord enfin lancer pas droit de
gauche c'est ce serait potentiellement
président est en marche mais mais nous
avons une capacité aujourd'hui de deux
d'avoir fait un travail législatif ou de
préparation très importante dans le gras
ça territoire unis qui peut être quand
même un terrain des approches
intéressant pour le gouvernement mais
justement territoire unis 7 c'est la
réunion des trois grandes associations
d'élus dans les régions les maires et
les départements se souvient qu'à
marseille territoire unis et n'est pas
ce que vous disiez l'état ne nous entend
pas le gouvernement ne nous entend pas
c'est un état recentralisateur
aujourd'hui vous dit le dialogue ça
marche
il est prêt sur la décentralisation est
ce que territoire unis encore une raison
d'être aujourd'hui présente plus encore
plus parce que finalement vous à l'e3
unis a été fait à marseille c'était sa
vie à marseille final on m'a fait la
marseillaise pour notre pays on envoie
quelques messages qui peuvent parfois
être écoutés tant mieux c'était quand
même je crois six mois avant les gilet
jaune à simon avant les jets les jeunes
se rendait bien compte que nous les
responsables politiques qu'il y avait un
problème de transfert de compétences des
coûte de difficultés dans les straps et
c'est que là haut ils écoutaient jamais
nulle part personne
il avait fait sauter tous les
dispositifs qui permettait souvent
d'amortir la décision de mieux
comprendre ou de l'harmoniser et on a eu
les gilet jaune dans l'ain ce qui veut
dire qu'on a anticipé je crois que le
gouvernement à l'époque avait réussi à
faire un truc incroyable c'est réunir
ces trois grandes associations qui
n'avait jamais été ensemble en fait
parce qu'il ya toujours une preuve de
compétence et je te prends telle ou
telle partie de ton pouvoir par rapport
aux et là aujourd'hui on est
parfaitement face on a beaucoup
travaillé ensemble pour le local les
maires ils ont la responsabilité
le département avec le social nous
l'économie nationale
du territoire la formation qui fait en
sorte que là dedans on pourrait être
beaucoup plus efficace puisque on est
d'accord et donc tes rides sont réunis à
encore plus de raisons de vivre
pascal oui donc toujours sur les régions
on parle d'un report de l'élection
régionale 1 quelle est votre position là
dessus
moi je pense que l'on peut discuter de
tout mais je crois qu'il faut pas trop
je reviens sur mes trois crises saverdun
crise sanitaire qui est difficile comme
dans bien d'emmener on est obligé de
vivre différemment
on n'a pas bien compris comment ça
marche et il ya eu beaucoup de
tergiversations qui ont emmené un doute
derrière on a une crise économique
majeure dans lequel le gouvernement
réagit plutôt très bien d'ailleurs
mais c'est pas sans fin dans un pays qui
quand même n'a pas les moyens en
permanence d'aidé à survivre quand il
faut qu'on reparte à la vie et donc ça
c'est très important que vous allez
avoir une crise sociale de toute façon
qui risque d'arriver fortement surtout
si une deuxième vague importante saison
que vous avez une crise sanitaire une
crise économique et sociale
nam n'est pas une crise politique sert à
quoi donc dans la crise politique si
vous ne dites quoi alors c'est en mars
alors ça veut dire que les efforts que
nous faisons aujourd'hui moi je fais les
efforts aujourd'hui avec ça pour pouvoir
vivre un noël pour voir les lumières qui
brillent les sapins les guirlandes et
les cadeaux ou la vie la vie de noël a
eu la trêve de noël à la joie des fêtes
dit maintenant ça veut dire est qu'un
joueur a prévenu en mars peu plus voûté
donner de l'air aux gens donc les cds
etc sur mars
et puis si ça va pas en mars ont fait
briller on pourra faire comment assure
municipal l'art est annulé bon c'est pas
c'est pas très compliqué si vous deviez
adresse sur le calendrier politique vous
mettez mars vous allez oust en juin
montrait bien vous gagnez 3 mois sur jeu
qua non après vous allez encore en
décembre
on descend vous le faire la veille des
présidentielles donc vous allez après
après les présidentielles vous allez
décalé de 18 mois dont vous rentrer dans
un débat permanent qui de nouveau
anxiogène on va avoir des arrière
pensées des uns des autres
dans le cas de sa réélection mais c'est
des choses tant qu'il laissait les
chausse trappes et disons les choses
regardons les choses avec lucidité avec
bon sens avec cal ne voyons pas des
arrière pensées partout aujourd'hui à 7
problème entre ce qui vient de se passer
pour ce pauvre professeur qui attaquent
la république en son sein et en même
temps c'est cette crise sanitaire qui
nous empêche de vivre
ouais c'est le médecin urgentiste qui
paraît que j'avais appris à chanter dans
l'urgence il faut être calme
voilà à priori vous serez consulté avant
noël donc pour le moment ça sera non à
la moi je moi je ne cherche même pas de
consulter d'ailleurs jeudi il a annoncé
une consultation web imagine que vous
serez dans la consultation
je pense qu'il serait ce à la
consultation mais je ne partirai pas un
comité des sages consultent d'abord je
suis pas le sage trop que c'est pas bien
un passage ça fait ça fait vieux et j'ai
pas l'impression d'être aux yeux même si
je suis né des donc voilà je vous prie
monsieur mais ce comité pour pour
consulter pour savoir si si si si c'est
pour enterrer le truc c'est une très
bonne idée
les hôpitaux vont obtenir le choc
puisque vous êtes aussi au contact dans
votre région et la société la métropole
aix marseille est touché il fallait
prendre ces décisions
est-ce que ça améliorer la situation
dans la métropole d'aix marseille les
deux le nom d'ag2 phase très difficile
très difficile à gérer c'est une
première phase où on nous avons nous
avons fermé nous quand les autres restés
ouverts alors qu'on avait les courbes
qui descendent et c'était donc un
sentiment d'injustice et d'inégalité un
supporter
donc là je me suis beaucoup battu parce
que j'ai beaucoup on est tous traités
pareil mais on n'a pas être nous traiter
à part sous prétexte que les marchés et
qu'enfin aux aixois c'est insupportable
c'était la raison du courroux initial
d'autant plus qu'à ce moment là
suivant les courbes que l'on prend on
était nous en décembre dans toutes les
cours les taux d'incidence le nombre de
lits en rien etc
pendant que tous les autres étaient
remontés donc il n'ya pas de raison pour
que nous on ferme pendant des heures des
années on est déjà sous de bon ça c'est
là ce qui s'est passé à trois semaines
la cesci passé cette semaine à paris
c'est une démarche qui était présent ce
totalité de la france on prendra tout
était la france moi je m'inscris en tout
cas alors vous me parlez des hôpitaux
parce que c'est comme ça qu'ils comptent
sur la santé des gens dans la santé des
gens on a effectivement une surchage
hospitalière de près de 40 %
d'occupation dans les rides rey à mes
fins
j'ai on a la capacité de résister de
tenir encore mais le mythe c'est gentil
ce que vous êtes dit c'était pas la
peine de prendre ces mesures
non je dis pas ça parce que si je dis ça
je ramène un débat dans un chaos donc
c'est pas la peine je dis je ne supporte
plus les avis du conseil scientifique
est qui qui donnent leur avis à tort
écrit dans ce truc qui doit l'être pour
conseiller les dirigeants qui ont des
décisions très difficiles à prendre
faire même pays c'est pas facile quand
on est au pouvoir
quand on en avait un qui vous dit alors
d'expression n'entend plus le professeur
delfraissy tant mieux ils ont dit pas ce
que c'est les mêmes qui nous gère
aujourd'hui qui nous ont géré la
première vague
c'est ce qui vous expliquer qu'ils
avaient pas le masque c'est ce qu'il ne
fallait pas se masquer y avait pas de
tests n'avaient pas testé et quand vous
étiez malade restez chez vous
tranquillement confiné pour transmettre
tous à vos voisins c'est ça qui nous ont
expliqué la première vague alors ça ça
aurait pas de la première fois c'est les
mêmes qui aujourd'hui dans le même
ministère nous explique qu'il faut
continuer à faire quelques erreurs et
bêtises
voilà cette fois ci je m'exprime un peu
plus jeunes invitent les membres du
conseil scientifique a conseillé mais à
se taire et puis qu'ils s'expriment les
expriment auprès des dirigeants qui
décident enfin quand vous avez dans un
le professeur fontanes et qui dit leurs
deux cent mille morts dans ce pays on
vient d éviter mais voilà et bien moi je
vous dis 1 3 million heureusement pour
les invités et alors parce que je suis
médecin que je suis je peux je dois dire
des choses comme ça mais c'est n'importe
quoi c'est très dangereux même et c'est
anxiogène
on est dans un pays qui souffre dans un
monde violent
on voit bien les difficultés qui
existent aujourd'hui pour apaiser tout
ça et il faut avoir un discours en
permanence avec un brin d'espoir et
d'espérance ne savait pas dire être un
béni oui oui ça veut pas dire ne pas
comprendre ça veut dire donner du rêve
et de l'espoir et travailler en ce sens
un dernier mot renaud muselier on a vu
une union des politiques marseillais au
moment de ces mesures
comment ça se passe entre le président
de région que vous êtes et la mère de
marseille michel renard
ça c'est un silence qui en dit long
parce que au delà de cette crise
sanitaire
à titre personnel j'ai plutôt de bonnes
relations avec elle donc ça c'est très
important
là elle était malade donc vous savez
qu'un quel point je suis très sensible à
ce genre de problème mais en même temps
j'ai un problème politique dans la
mesure où je sais pas qui pilote l'avion
quoi et donc comme elle était absente
que son premier adjoint prendre toute la
lumière que sa deuxième adjointe anne
galy ne manquent pas d'apprendre et
qu'elle essaye de prendre les tofu ferme
mesure je lui souhaite de prendre le
plus vite possible habits pour que je
puisse avoir un interlocuteur
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas un interlocuteur
c'est quand même pour le moment n'a pas
endossé son costume de maire de
marseille mais c'est surtout j'ai même
pas pu la voir sur traiter les dossiers
toujours pas non donc c'est j'ai vu tous
les maires de la région sans problème
politique je vois le maire jésuite avec
lui voilà ma politique ce que je fais
dans ma cop d'avant selon plan climat
dans l'aménagement du territoire dans
mes trains dans les lycées dans mes
enfants et puis je vois avec eux leurs
programmes leurs projets je vois ce qui
peut se marier
enfin la vie normale d'une discussion de
deux responsables politiques dans le
cadre de la responsabilité pour mettre
en place un dispositif marseille dans ma
ville qu'en fait que j'aime
fondamentalement bien sûr je suis
marseillais ben j'arrive pas encore pour
l'instant à traiter les dossiers et le
maire quoi c'est un peu difficile et ça
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
merci aux nouveaux ailiers d'avoir été
avec nous
[Musique]